and uh y'all have probably seen it aoc
calls out capital police after troll
calls her big booty latina on the hill
steps so that was it uh that was you who
called her your favorite big booty
latina and you were very happy and
smiling and saying you loved her and all
that stuff she got mad and so i'll just
clarify right away
i knew that aoc made the statement about
capitol police and the insurrection
being implying it was an inside job that
their police inside opening the doors i
just didn't realize that she was making
a point about you specifically
and so i will walk back my statement uh
what i said earlier today was that
for one i think your culture jamming is
fantastic we've we've talked about how
we want to do culture jamming more as a
marketing tool and also to affect change
and that you've done a particularly good
job of that i don't think that calling
aoc a big woody latina solved or did
anything i was wrong it actually got her
to come out and issue a prominent
statement that january 6 was uh that
people that police officers in the
building opened the door that would not
have happened where it not for something
to me seemed completely inane and here
we are i'm uh i'm flabbergasted and you
should be and it is completely inane and
let me tell you something i am mentally
insane like i said i call myself
primetime because i am insane and this
is the thing though tim uh even though i
am an imbecile and an idiot i want to
say that i actually planned this i i
talked about this earlier aoc constantly
says that she's a victim of
sexualization she says the people on the
right do not like her because they want
to date her there was a picture of her
boyfriend now fiance in miami with his
feet and everybody said ooh look at her
gross feet and she you know of course
she whatever my point being is
for her it's all about like image and
looks and that's why people don't like
her so my thought was if i run into
elaine omar i'm going to say i think you
married your brother is that what
happened you know i had i had stuff you
know for each congresswoman of the squad
but for aoc i said instead of like i
called out adam kenzinger and i called
him you know a trader and a d-bag but my
point being is
when you call people out and you're kind
of like aggressive that doesn't work
that's not culture jamming that's like
being rude so in my mind i said you know
what i'm going to give aoc what she
wants i'm going to bait her and i'm
going to sexualize her and actually you
know i called this on on sarah
gonzalez's show on the blaze before i
said i'm going to call her big booty
latina but i did it i did it on purpose
so the reason why
i thought
i would go to city council meetings at
the very beginning uh you know of the
coveted pandemic and i would talk
seriously you know and they wouldn't pay
attention they would look at me like i
was an idiot like a conspiracy you know
theorists which i am a tinfoil hat
wearing but my point being is you
couldn't you couldn't get an evoke a
response and then one of the first
meetings is we have a mayor johnson he's
a nice guy and i said you know they're
pushing the vaccine real hard i said you
should offer free vaccines in the gay
neighborhood you should call it eric
johnson's free johnson johnson because
the gay community will love the
double-entrancer and since you're the
first openly gay mayor of dallas they'll
really love it he's not he's married
with kids and he was shook you know he
was just his face like a pumpkin
he was just like you know what and
that's when i kind of realized all right
i have to troll these people and
my comedic hero is andy kaufman and what
he did brilliantly is he blended the
line of reality and fiction so you
couldn't tell so my point being you know
i just long-winded with aoc i said i'm
going to try to get an emotional
response by hitting on her but i want
her to think i'm serious i want her to
think i actually like her and then in
her tweet when i said you're a big booty
latina she actually ended up coming back
and trying to take some sort of selfie
with me so she liked the compliments i
did in front of her fiance who i totally
said let's get a selfie or something
like that yes that's exactly what she
said and then she like gave a peace sign
and she did but yet you know the
narrative after was that she wanted to
deck me which is obviously provably
false well she tweeted about it and
deleted it
because what was the first thing she
tweeted well she came out her staffer
came out after it happened because
they're like who is this guy and they
came and took this picture right in
front of my face i said i'm alex stein
like i'm on the blaze here's my business
card you know like you know i'm not
trying to hide and of course they didn't
like that and then when they figured out
who i was that i'm this right wing troll
that you know and i'll call myself a
troll you know i'm a goblin i'm whatever
whatever adjective you want to call me i
agree with it my point being
is when i when i came out i admitted who
i was that's when she was triggered she
just couldn't stand it that some
right-wing guy you know got her and she
didn't want to get got so of course her
ego was just totally shattered so she
had to create this new narrative that i
said juicier that i said ass which i
never said the video proves that
and my point being in all of this is i
laid out a trap and i'm not like i said
i'm an idiot but i knew i was going to
evoke emotional response to him but i
had no idea that it would be this big of
a response she would make so many
instagram videos that she'd make a post
asking people questions about it and
then
so so uh i stand corrected
my my thought was like you did this
thing and what was the point i
understand your point now and in fact it
triggered aoc to call out the police in
the capitol and directly implicate the
1-6 committee investigation literally
saying they're not investigating this i
don't feel safe
and
wow you put those pieces together and
it's
you know i don't think you expected her
to indict the 1 6 committee in response
to you trolling her on like you know
she's notorious for saying people want
to date her and things like that and
that's why i said that though right i
stand corrected i i
and so the reason
that we're seeing her response is
because she has to bury her emotional
reaction she's probably getting a ton of
heat from democrats over what she said
about the police in january 6. and so
she's leaning as heavily into the i was
harassed thing as possible to dominate
news coverage to shut down the 1-6
conversation and she's right i mean i
did cross the line a little bit of of
course i hit on her
but at the same time i was very nice you
know what i mean i mean i don't care
what you're saying yeah i'm laughing i'm
nice i'm saying you're a big buddha dina
i think you're sexy even though you want
to you know abort and kill babies i
still love you you know and that was my
whole point is i try to actually be nice
because the people on the left marjorie
taylor green friend of mine she's great
she says on the capital steps she'll get
harassing or the b word the c word all
this mean stuff that doesn't have the
same effect like if you start doing that
a politician's going to put their head
down and go about their business but as
soon as you try to get them in a trap
you're either nice to them by being you
know trolling them
that's how we win the culture war is by
evoking a response
oh yeah so uh we've been
married
yeah you said look at something yeah
well i want to know what culture jamming
means okay so culture jamming is where
you take the most absurd parts of our
culture and you jam it in people's face
to bring awareness because even people
that agree with the mainstream narrative
they don't even know what the mainstream
narrative is like one video oh go ahead
i don't know well let me just say this
so like one thing beto o'rourke's
running for governor of texas and so one
of my buddies cassidy campbell is a big
youtube channel we you know i make all
kinds of content but we do a thing where
we'll go like fake door knocking or
really door knocking and we'll talk
about beto works like real thing how he
wants to give you know gender
reassignment surgery to seven-year-old
kids and even people that are like you
know as leftist as kids they're kind of
like i don't know if a seven-year-old
should be on that you know so what are
you transphobic oh no i'm actually trans
i'm genderfluid i'm alexandria half the
time you'll see you can pull it up me
alex stein and alexandria stein in a
bathing suit yeah we should pull that up
but my point being the culture jamming
it's just exposing the craziest aspects
of our culture here's a really good
example uh james o'keefe
went i don't know if he personally did
but veritas i think it might have been
veritas or maybe it was actually just
james they went door-to-door and they
asked people if they were if they they
said we're a group that supports gun
control and we don't like people to you
know having guns it's dangerous do you
agree and they're like yes of course and
they said we would love it if you would
put this sign in your lawn saying proud
gun-free home and the people went
no no no i'm not doing that and they're
like why not like because you're like
inviting people to rob you and then they
go it sounds like you're saying you need
guns no no no i just i don't want that
is culture jamming
those kind of stunts that that
expose
and as you said like jam it in their
face but it's just like uh
exposing the absurdities of of you know
things that are happening
satire so yeah it's like real it's
activism in a sense it's it's making a
point
you can go to someone and you can be
super liminal hey
x you know i will tell you thing we need
guns to stay safe we have those rights
and people are going to argue with you
about it but you go to them and get them
to tell you we will not
let people know we don't like guns
that's a secret and you're like hmm i
wonder about that right so you didn't
know that she was going to speak on 1 6
when you did that but what were you
hoping would happen well i just hope i
got a response just any sort of response
yeah i didn't know that she was going to
actually take my video and download it
and reshare it you know she literally
screen recorded it and reshared it i
couldn't believe that you know it's got
millions of hits on her twitter um so i
got i just got to say i i feel like you
slipped on a banana peel but pulled off
a perfect backflip from it 100 but
that's
but see that's the thing it's you know
you miss 100 of the shots you don't take
when gretzky michael scott so my point
being is you have to actually you know
go out there and try this like it could
have been a dud of course but when
you're actually on the grind and this is
for people watching at home i just want
to say you have to go try you know and
i'm a tryhard for lack of a better word
and it worked not every time does it
work but this one was gangbusters it
made me think of kavanaugh who lately
recently had been harassed by people
standing outside a restaurant was trying
to eat a steak and that was first thing
i thought i was like oh okay so this is
kind of like
i don't know if he's putting it back in
someone's or at least bringing it the
thing about the kavanaugh thing was it
wasn't televised so there's no video
evidence of it we heard about it under
the rug but the she made a statement uh
alex after you did that alex and alex
hey that's pretty cool you should do a
talk show a a um
and that people aren't saying the
government's not designed to protect
people and i think that's kind of true
like that they have like you were saying
they get harassed often walking up the
steps to work we know where they are we
know where they're centralized what
building they're in like that's not
secure for people to be making laws that
are angering people or could potentially
anger a lot of people well she said that
aoc tweeted that we need to make these
people uncomfortable that was exactly
her exact words so that's what i was
trying to do i wanted to make her
uncomfortable now i didn't want to cross
the line i didn't want to say like the p
word or ass i didn't say ass but i
wanted to take it to the limit and
that's what i like to do i like to
tiptoe the line of reality and fiction
because i wanted to actually think that
i'm attracted to her and to be honest
aoc's politics are terrible but she is
very attractive i have to give her that
i'm telling you she's got a very pert
petite derriere it's not big booty it's
actually pretty
nice and
pert you know oh my gosh how old are you
perk plus uh is my shampoo so i'd say i
see that word a lot i you know i i don't
i don't agree i don't understand why
though you know what people would say
that to me i think she's rather horsey
when she opens her mouth but when her
mouth is closed she looks okay cute yeah
i'm not very picky
she's got a pulse and she's breathing
right yeah well not even that i'm just
saying you know she is uh she's in good
shape i think she checks a lot of the
boxes and i can see why she actually got
in her position she's 32 years old she's
one of the most popular congresswoman
but she actually in her netflix our
community she basically got casted for
that you know she was basically almost
like a casting call
and so i can see why she got picked
almost like you get picked for a reality
show or something she has the look she
has the you know she's articulate even
though what she's saying is you know
garbage
she there's a reason why she's
successful because she actually is easy
on the eyes what's the netflix stock i
haven't heard of this yet it's becoming
aoc i believe is the name of it and it
was coming
something like that we google it real
quick i forget the name but in that it
talks about how you know multiple
multiple people for her district you
know submitted for you know basically to
get the nomination thanks for checking
out this clip from timcast irl come hang
out live monday through friday at 8 pm
eastern time super chat will even answer
some of your questions if you want to
check out the after hours censored show
go to timcast.com and become a member we
put those up monday through thursday at
11 pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time